back in the west side we're in Westwood
when do we come back here well the last
time I came back here you were might
have been LED might have been 2009 when
I graduated from UCLA but we're back
here hoping to find the young monkey
cheeto a good doctor
[Music]
you know what's crazy
I do not remember a lot
maybe it was a very traumatizing time
when I was studying my brains off I
remember a lot of what this area the
area yeah has it developed since you've
left or is it the same it's exactly the
sandwiches there used to be a Pinkberry
right there oh so I guess I do remember
a little bit but barely
Broxton so that is a
what is a movie theater here somewhere
well I used to be a CPK right here
okay why are you talking all this crud
and then I believe there was a yeah
there is a junior out here that wasn't
the here when I was here obviously
um there it is UCLA health
we think we get a discount if I tell
them you're uh an Alum alumni I wish
they don't all they ever do is call me
and go hey do you want to donate I'm a
man rich foreign
oh man we're about to go on campus on
campus
yeah because if you cross that street
LeConte as yourself hey
um that is the campus Because I thought
we're gonna go here which is the health
building because UCLA there's a UCLA
Medical Center UCLA health they're all
different actually they're all different
companies
of research one's like a actual Hospital
you know they're all different yeah
because the first one we went to was in
downtown L.A remember yeah
but we're actually going to go on campus
nice to holla at all the Honeys there
you know what I'm saying
that
boy
Honeys love you
second floor
[Music]
no way Jose are you kidding me dude
the police are gonna come dude are you
crazy bones are you crazy bones or what
good
look how CUNY this waiting room is
everything has an animal look
s called Rabbit Run for room one
you got giraffling from room two and
then you've got Fox Trail or room four
just cutie pie what is that a bear bear
path for room five your shoes then
you're gonna stand right there
oh whoa give me the again what do you
guys stand oh okay you're taking your
shoes off
oh you got them on tight huh
49 whoa 50 pounds a little 50 pounder
let's see how tall you are you're gonna
come find over here put your back to the
wall
good job
see okay now step out come out let's see
all right he's at 46 inches
[Music]
I've never seen anyone use a sword like
a gun before that's awesome dude okay
um
um
[Music]
so uh yeah he's like easily irritable he
um mood swings on six milligrams yes
okay can you follow my finger no keep
your head just your eyes just your eyes
yes yes
I keep looking you're gonna look weird
and stick out your tongue
wiggle your tongue
good job puff up your chips
like this look awesome
like a blowfish put air in your mouth
all right good can you whistle
so we're done with our first doctor
appointment at UCLA with a brand new
neurologist how do you like her so far
I don't know I feel relieved
really I don't know I'm about to cry
I thought you were gonna pretend cry and
then you really cry what the hell is
that you're a psychopath you know that I
was trying to you are a psycho I can't
believe I married you I was trying to
hold it in and then I couldn't but
you're pretend trying to hold it in I
was and then you realize
okay
pathic ways
not even a dog
never [ __ ] cry but
yeah it feels I feel relief I feel like
cool someone that speaks the language I
understand and uses emotion it felt like
his other neurologist was just such a
[ __ ] robot yeah like a computer and
there's hope I think I think that's why
you feel so overwhelmed so with our
original neurologist
yeah she felt so textbook where like
when we go in and you know obviously you
go in with a lot of feelings like oh man
my kids you know my kid is having
seizures at school and then you know
this happens and then like he wets his
bed and go in or like what's his pants
and she's just like uh-huh uh-huh so if
that's not working then we bump up the
dosage and then with the dosage now you
have to get blood work and all this
stuff and you're just like what and then
he has to get another scan and you have
to put him under and he has to go to
sleep and he has a good sedated and
you're like
what yeah and then so now with this
current dosage she's already on the max
which is like six milliliters for his
um body weight we're like hey we he's
still got seizures with
um this dosage and she's like well we
have to start a second one the second
one is going to be crazy because he
needs blood work because it's gonna have
to regulate his like sodium levels and
we're like uh are there other
Alternatives like what can we do
whatever and then we pitched the
alternative of like okay we want to do a
ketogenic diet well that's not gonna
work I've never seen it work like in
Long uh like uh longevity or whatever
right and I'm thinking I come from a
fitness background where we understand a
crazy amount of dieting I know so many
people that have a sustainable
life with on a ketogenic diet and I'm
like what is this lady talking about
like it just felt like everything was a
dead end and I just hit a wall and that
the only solution is like the most
extreme thing ever and I'm like this
doesn't feel right yeah so instead of
like
um
explaining things where there's like
logical deduction and then you're kind
of ruling things out and then creating
new Pathways and game plan to achieving
a goal it was it just seemed like there
was only her way and then that's it and
then with this new uh neurologist she's
freaking awesome because the first thing
she did was like let me look at that
video and so even her watching the
Halloween video she would like analyze
and point out things that we didn't even
see in body language and then she was
like oh okay so that looks like it's
focal onset second regeneralization
meaning like the seizure start in one
place like of one specific focal point
and then it hits the whole body and then
so she goes so that opens it up to a
bunch of different medications that can
address the focal part and then it can
redress address the general part and
we're like oh that's cool and then I'm
like okay so just because I'm like so um
like so
used to like yeah emotionally so used to
like uh people like not working with me
I was like okay so like let's say it
doesn't work what do you do she goes
then what I would do she goes um I would
look at re-run all the EEG and MRI scans
because obviously the ones that you have
they don't show any uh weird activity
but obviously he's getting seizures so
to me that shows that that's a poor
quality report and I'm like oh man the
fact that she's even down to retrace
steps versus the other neurologist
under yeah versus the other neurologist
just goes like well that's what the
reports say that's what the reports say
and I'm like you know I guess that if
that's what the reports say but then
this doctor was like well there is a
difference between high quality bad
quality reports and I would find the the
person that can do the highest quality
report in this hospital and have them do
it to see if because then they're going
to be able to like you know when you
think when things are being measured
here how can they measure here to see if
something pops under and then when
there's no other choice yeah we have to
do that other final one where we have to
put them under and she didn't even
really want to and that part was so cool
too because she was just relating like
mother to mother like she was like you
know like I have a seven-year-old I
wouldn't want to put my kid under and
the other doctor was like no problem oh
yeah if you want First shows reluctant
if you want to run it again
then go ahead but we already have a
report and then if you want to if we run
into each other and I was like whoa
that's crazy you know so so far we have
a lot more hope
um it is going to be much more of a pain
in the ass coming to La every single
time but it's super worth it because
we're actually getting somewhere it's
not just one dead end and we're trying
to bang our head through a wall and go
okay this doesn't work let's Force
another way you know it's like Well yeah
if we can't get to this wall maybe you
can jump over the wall dig underneath
you know where there's so many other
options and uh definitely feels like a
sense of relief huh
by the way all these streets right here
I used to jog all the time did you know
that
what
muscles of your
s of your plump and juicy you never
wanted to suck on all of them
that's what succulent means right you
want to suck on them
how do you move your eyes like that to
the side
like a freaking frog
yeah I used to jog all these streets
brings back all these memories
nice it's nice huh it's so alive but
there's also a lot of traffic but it
just feels like it has a lot of energy
alive and dead yep it's alive and dead
okay ma'am they'll quote you is that
what you said
oh he said don't copy me I said don't
copy me now okay
which doctor do you like better mister
did you like Dr Chacon or did you like
this one and as soon as she saw him she
gave him a little toy and she was so
tender with him yeah the other one was
trying to correct his behavior like can
you sit still we need to sit still when
we see a doctor and I was like [ __ ]
which doctor do you like better
oh of course
remember we used to cruise these streets
you'd come visit me and we bump Cascade
on the car oh right
damn you had the hots for me a long time
oh yeah yeah I don't know
all these streets I remember cruising
all these streets
now all three of us get to cruise yeah
that's cutie pie that's whole circle
It's Raining Tacos
let me concentrate real quick hold on so
right now we're teaching taika
um okay so between good words and bad
words no I'm even I'm putting it into
more categories so he can really
regulate like self-regulate okay so
there's polite words right so polite
words would be like excuse me ma'am
thank you those are polite words then
you have friend Words which is like sup
bro sup say what those are friend words
they're like oh Beast those are friend
words and then you have not polite words
like what's a not polite word
Pizza yeah those are not polite right
and the not polite words would be like
uh what was like you said butthole
that's not polite that's disgusting and
then we have bad words and those are the
really really bad ones what's a bad word
um stupid [ __ ]
those are really bad what's another one
um
what part of it is bad what word is bad
yeah we don't want to say those those
are really bad and [ __ ] [ __ ] baby
a baby baby
those are really nice those are really
bad monkey I don't want to hear any more
of those but those are like Poetic
everybody's successful lesson here
what was the other one that you said
stupid what stupid [ __ ]
those are really bad those can hurt
people's feelings really bad okay
no serious you should never ever say
those okay and and all the bad word too
what hey don't press my little baby old
lady no that's not polite that's not
pleasant those are not polite words
[Music]
peace
quick little day and a half trip it is
now 11.
27 at night
so you know we're tired as [ __ ] and
Barbara's really excited about something
what is it coffee table came in
oh damn player
dude this is hella nice
pesto
so all of our little interior design
pieces have been slowly coming in so
we're going to be swapping stuff out
like that's gonna keep going because
everything's gonna fit a certain vibe
we got all this stuff over here
all that stuff needs to get installed
really really excited you can't tell I'm
excited because I'm tired but I am very
excited that we found a new Nero
biologist
and I'm so happy that we have more paths
to take and hopeful and we will fix
little Tyga
and good night everybody